[Música]
[Aplausos]
pues si la sordoceguera existe y ya va
siendo hora de que sea considerada como
lo que es una particularidad única y no
la suma de dos condiciones como son la
sordera y la ceguera
para ello vamos a tener que empezar a
ver las diferencias cómo se comunican
qué tipo de planteamiento conlleva la
autonomía personal no es lo mismo ser
sordo ciego que tener sordera o ceguera
vamos a ver las diferencias una persona
sorda
puede apoyarse en la lengua de signos
puede utilizar en la lectura la
escritura
una persona ciega tendrá que utilizar el
braille tendrá que utilizar él
código oral podrá comunicarse de forma
oral y al mismo tiempo también podrá
apoyarse en las distintas nuevas
tecnologías que están favoreciendo la
comunicación en este sector
para una persona sordociega todo
distinto
la mayor cantidad de información que
recibe viene del tacto
prácticamente todo lo que esté fuera del
alcance de mis manos no existe para mí y
esa es la realidad de las personas con
sordoceguera no hay nada más allá del
alcance de mis manos
bueno y que conlleva nos podemos
encontrar con multitud de situaciones
que vamos a analizar podemos
encontrarnos con personas que tienen
resto visual pueden aprovechar un poco
la vista pero no escuchan nada no tienen
audición estas personas tendrán que
apoyar su comunicación con la lengua de
signos y también podrán utilizar ese
resto visual con algunas
particularidades por eso por eso las
guías e intérpretes van de negro y no
porque estén más guapas o también sino
porque van a beneficiarse de la
capacidad visual
si esta persona tampoco contase con
resto visual no oye ni ve entonces
tendremos que utilizar otra serie de
técnicas mucho más especializadas como
pueden ser la lengua de signos apoyada
la dactilografía etcétera etcétera
etcétera
y ahora nos vamos a encontrar con otro
caso diferente que es el que no tiene
resto visual no ve absolutamente nada
pero tiene un resto auditivo que aunque
malo le permite desenvolverse moralmente
aquí podemos apoyarnos en por supuesto
la comunicación oral tendremos un nivel
de autonomía personal mucho más limitado
al no obtener posibilidades visuales y
tendremos que utilizar algunos recursos
en autonomía en herramientas de
autonomía personal como puede ser un
perro guía tendrá que ser un bastón pero
no cualquier bastón tendremos que
utilizar
uno como este que tiene unos colores muy
marcados y no son los de mi equipo
favorito no en este caso tienen que ser
rojiblanco para diferenciarlo y
señalizar que el portador de esta
herramienta de este bastón además de
tener problemas visuales también tiene
dificultades muy grave auditiva
con todo esto tenemos que jugar
en las particularidades actuales
hemos hablado de muchos problemas de
muchas situaciones pero la mayoría están
centradas en la comunicación
y en la autonomía personal
ahora
dicho esto no podemos compararlas allá
por el año 1881 cuando helen keller que
la mayoría les podrá sonar fue la
primera persona con sordoceguera que
tuvo que enfrentarse a las condiciones
de la época
de hablar de tecnología era una utopía
hablar de aspectos sociales o de apoyos
gubernamentales eran pues simplemente no
existían y esas circunstancias
comprenderán ustedes que eran muy
difíciles y muy distintas hoy yo no
engañaría a nadie si les dijese si les
dijese que hoy ser sordo ciego tiene
unas ventajas que no había en aquella
época y por supuesto es menos difícil
ser sordo ciego hoy que hace 20 30 o 40
años bueno llegados a este extremo yo
creo que ya podríamos empezar a sacar
una serie de conclusiones y yo les
pondría a tres yo no me quiero extender
mucho en cantidades pero la primera si
sería necesario establecer un marco
legal una norma que aglutina todas y
cada una de las necesidades que
requieren la atención de este colectivo
para su mejor
y administrativo no existe ya va siendo
hora
segundo he hecho esto y de forma
complementaria tendremos que establecer
y elaborar un censo que sea capaz de
identificar localizar y ubicar a todos y
cada una de las personas con
sordoceguera para que seamos capaces de
prestarles el mejor y más digno apoyo
para que su calidad de vida sea la mejor
y tercero no por eso menos importante ya
tendremos que establecer mecanismos de
visibilidad visibilización para que la
sociedad sea capaz de no tenerle miedo a
la sordoceguera ser capaces de
comunicarnos si yo les dijese que con
una simple acto como tomarle la mano a
una persona sordociega y escribiendo en
su palma la letra que queremos
establecer el alfabeto ya estamos
estableciendo comunicación estamos
intercambiando información sencillo
verdad como hemos podido comprobar
estamos jugando con voluntad
y en este caso la persona sordociega
quieren y pueden y ustedes quieren
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]